and now joining us on book TV is
University of Arizona professor William
Mishler professor what do you do here at
the University I'm a professor of
political science in the school of
government and public policy what do you
teach I teach a variety of things I
teach theories of democracy and
democratization a little statistics and
the intro to American government well
we're here to talk to you about your
book popular support for an undemocratic
regime the changing views of Russians
it's Vladimir Putin in your view
democratically elected yeah probably you
know what it was a an election which had
a variety of undemocratic features but
if the question is had there been a free
and fair election in every regard would
he have won I think the answer is
probably yes you know all elections have
some sorts of anomalies Russia has more
than most but yeah he was probably
elected democratically that doesn't make
Russia a democracy explain well there's
more than simply how leaders are
selected there's also how they they
govern of I think there's no doubt that
Putin covers in a more authoritarian
manner the the Duma has far less
influenced and than you would expect in
a democratic system there are questions
about judicial independence not so much
for rank-and-file individuals who might
have suits with one another but in terms
of citizens trying to get recompense
from the government for anything so when
it comes to the Duma what power does it
have does it can it override a law can
it enact laws
well it certainly can enact laws and it
has considerable power on paper but it's
controlled by the president Putin's
party they have the votes they and
essentially they turn the Duma into what
is essentially a rubber stamp for the
for the president and what about the
judiciary why do you doubt its
independence well I think some of the
decisions they've they've made about
high-ranking officials who have been in
contestation with the regime and the
high-ranking officials almost always
lose okay the subtitle of your book
popular support for an undemocratic
regime the changing views of Russians
explain the subtitle well so this book
is the near culmination of about 20 25
years of research with Richard rose a
professor now at Strathclyde University
in Scotland we began really shortly
after the fall of the wall and the
freeing of Eastern Europe concerned with
how ordinary people cope with the
extraordinary events that are associated
with a collapse of a long-standing
regime along with the collapse of the
long-standing economic system in some
cases as in the case of Russia with the
disappearance of the state altogether
same in former Czechoslovakia Yugoslavia
and so on so you had these myriad of
dramatic political changes that affected
citizens and the question was how do
ordinary citizens cope with that and the
early years the question also was to
what extent can citizens learned
citizens who spent their entire lives
under a communist system with a
socialist economy how can they learn to
become democratic citizens and to be
effective
participants in
market economies along the way Russia in
a couple other states turn from what
appeared to be democratic transitions
that to a different form of
authoritarian or semi authoritarianism
and so then the question became what
happens to those citizens who were freed
from authoritarian regimes thought they
might be developing towards a democratic
system and suddenly find themselves at
least slipping backwards into something
quite different from the past but also
quite different from what their
democratic expectations might have been
and we chose to to write that book on on
Russia because it's changes were the
most obvious early on and and it's a
more interesting country to write about
them than Hungary or Romania or one of
the stands from your book
Putin benefited from the popular desire
for the consolidation of order after the
turbulence of transformation yeah so the
early years of the transformation were
chaotic on the Yeltsin also committed in
some respects to a democratic transition
wasn't very effective in getting the
economy moving he wasn't very effective
in dealing with the Chechen rebellion
wasn't very effective in getting along
with the parties that were ascendant in
the in the Duma Yeltsin came along and
restored a measure of of order that
might have come along anyway I'm not
sure that this is something that Putin
did
the economy was trending better before
Putin came to office but he gets credit
for the economy in the same way that the
Trump is already claiming credit for an
economy that's been improving for
several for several years the there's no
doubt that Putin has restored a measure
of stability at home there's far less
political infighting than there was but
but I think we give him much too much
credit for stabilizing things in Russia
and I think we give him much too much
credit for being popular in in Russia
he's if you look at public opinion polls
these days he probably up there around
with around 70 percent favorable
probably something like twenty percent
unfavorable that's down 10 percentage
points or so in the past year from his
high point but that popularity is a mile
wide and an inch deep and a lot of it
simply has to do with the fact that the
public at this point can't conceive of
anybody else as as leader he's been in
so long he's been such a fixture things
have been good under him we talk in the
book about resigned acceptance that
Russians adult to resigned acceptance to
the the current regime and to its
leaders they don't much like them but
there's not enough bad about them to
make them truly angry there really is
nothing they can do about it so they
might as well simply make peace and go
along and hope that they'll go away
sooner or later and something better
will be on offer
how much corruption is there in Russia
you write four-fifths of Russians see
public officials as inclined to take
bribes yeah
and probably something on the order of
I'll get this drawing from memory but
about a quarter of Russians say that
they've paid a bribe in the past two
years or so the second figure those
reporting bribe pain is reasonably high
the percentage saying they think their
officials are corrupt not all that high
most many citizens in most countries
including our own tend to see their
political officials as corrupt to a
significant extent so you know
corruption is hard to talk about it's
invisible the ways we measure it as
political scientists are all bad and the
best we can do is make an educated guess
and I wouldn't put much of my of my
salary on how much corruption there is
in Russia as opposed to France or Italy
or even the US although most Russians do
vote more than five five six think they
have little or no influence on what the
government does yeah and they're right
but voters don't in any country as
individuals the odds that your vote will
affect the outcome of the election
America one in ten million probably less
than that varies by state so you know
Russian citizens don't feel very
empowered this isn't something that's
unusual for them or unique to them is
there somebody in the wings that could
take on Vladimir Putin I don't know I
the interesting thing is although I've
been working on Russian politics for the
past quarter century I'm not really a
Russian expert I'm a public opinion
specialist who's chosen Russia as an
interesting case and so I've learned a
little bit
about Russia but if any of my true
russian scholar friends see this they'll
say yeah he's right he doesn't really
know that much about russia is it easy
to measure public opinion in russia now
yeah so that's one of the counter
indications of Russia being
authoritarian although they've cracked
down on public opinion polling to some
extent they haven't prohibited it so you
can go into the country and work with an
independent poll polling company who's
not affiliated with the government and
you can ask just about any questions
that you want to ask and I say just
about as far as I know you can ask any
question we've no one reads our
questionnaire no one approves our
questionnaire we ask questions about you
know what do you like about Putin and
what don't you like about him and and
people give us answers we have little
tricks we can play in terms of asking
people questions to try to tell if
they're lying to us or not and the
evidence is they're telling us as much
of the truth as anybody tells a pollster
so professor Mishler what's the takeaway
in this book
well the takeaway in the book is that
people support undemocratic regimes for
the same reason they support democratic
regimes they like regimes that provide
peace and prosperity a modicum of
individual both security and freedom
it's it's telling that although Putin is
certainly reduce freedom of the press
and all that we find that that has
that's a drag on his popularity he
hasn't tried to repeal freedom of
religion he hasn't tried to take
people's votes away from them he hasn't
done a variety of other things limit
freedom of travel and those sorts of
things that Russians like and and which
they reward him for the other takeaway
is that governments survive over time by
inertia once a governments in power it
survives the first election or
succession or - it's hard to change and
it's really hard to change if there
isn't a significant change on offer and
right now in Russia there's no person
anybody knows on horizon who could take
on Putin and have any reasonable chance
of success in over the next two years
four years five years I'm not sure what
the horizon is that can change pretty
quickly but for right now if Putin's in
power Putin popularity is is wide but
but thin support for the regime is much
less than support for Putin and and and
Putin's popularity I think is starting
to slip as well the professor the author
is Professor William Mishler the book is
called popular support for an
undemocratic regime the changing views
of Russians this is book TV on c-span -
on location at the University of Arizona